Law and Order Special Victims Unit is
known for its compelling characters
hard-hitting subject matter and nuanced
storylines although the detectives are
confronted with brutal realities on the
show every day the atmosphere behind the
scenes appears to be full of camaraderie
and laughter the cast and crew seem to
genuinely enjoy working together
Fellowship forged naturally after more
than two decades on the air this
friendly Dynamic is especially
impressive given that so many cast
members have come and gone over the
years however we still get the
occasional Cameo from fan favorite
actors who are no longer series regulars
although Christopher Maloney left Law
and Order SVU Following season 12 Elliot
Stabler still interacts with the
Manhattan Special Victims Unit during
crossover episodes with Law and Order
organized crime while Maloney was a main
player on SVU for many years he was
ultimately outlasted by co-star Ice-T
who says he'll stay on the show as long
as fellow series staple Mariska hargate
is still there he usually feels like a
reunion when all the characters get to
share the screen again though there's a
rumor going around that Christopher
Maloney and iced tea are feuding behind
closed doors thankfully ice tea didn't
allow this claim to gain online traction
the longtime law order SVU Mainstay was
quick to let fans know the truth in the
bluntest way possible whether it's
busting heads or busting balls nobody
gets one over on fin as reported by
parade iced tea was recently contacted
by The National Enquirer in regards to
the supposed rivalry between himself and
Maloney on the SVU set according to the
Outlet's claims iced and his former
co-star have been on the outs ever since
Maloney returned to the Law and Order
franchise The Inquirer wanted to run a
story suggesting that the former rapper
has grown jealous of the attention
melonius received following stabler's
comeback the yst has made sure to let
viewers know that these were nothing
more than baseless claims the actor
wrote on Twitter alongside a screenshot
of the message he was received from the
offending Outlet just sent this email
over to my guy Chris Maloney clown ass
MFS trying to make up drama out of thin
air wow MFS are really on that BS in
response to this clarification numerous
fans commented Under Ice T's tweet to
voice their relief that there was no bad
blood between the two Law and Order SVU
icons for some even making fun of the
debunked story of course it shouldn't
come as a surprise that iced tea wasn't
the only one who had something to say
about the supposed Feud Christopher
Maloney also chimed in to refute the
claims and have a little fun with them
in a social media post of his own the
actor provided further confirmation that
the rumor is unfounded when he joked on
Twitter so iced tea was sent this he was
kind enough to let me know we were
feuding ice tea replied to Maloney's
tweet as well writing Chris is my MF man
FM they just make BS up crazy hey I'm
here for whatever you need man
appreciate it it's nice to know that ice
tea and Christopher Maloney have each
other's backs when it comes to tabloid
scrutiny both actors have starring roles
on their respective shows so a petty
Feud about screen time doesn't make much
sense anyway if anything this situation
provides further proof that the gossip
Mill isn't always to be believed thanks
to their honest and hilarious responses
to this rumor those hoping to see Elliot
Stabler and Finn to Ola cross paths down
the road on Law and Order programming
don't have anything to worry about
[Music]